your LT is trying to run  talk to me pinche pendejo  who's this deserter you're looking for  some huevos marycoon de mierda who ran  up from the training camp boss says we  get to make an example out of him so the  others don't get the same idea we're  gonna drag him back and let the other  recruits take turns on him with a  machete where is this little chicken  [ __ ] now we don't know for sure yet but  we're getting close one of the other  search parties thinks they found his  trail where's this other search party  tell me and maybe I'll let you go okay  you Cajun we're closing in on the  deserter let's sweep the area where he  was spotted and see if we can find him  captain just spotted submachine guns  this bad guy  tango Down  target down  you